trois centenaires honoré news valises
sentant les sibenik fairgrounds st600 et
viola fletcher 107 en sont les derniers
survivants connu de lundi pires
massacres ratio de l'histoire américaine
une tragédie longtemps ignorée
[Musique]
aujourd'hui cette enseignante apprend à
ses élèves ce qui s'est déroulé dans
leur quartier mais pendant des décennies
sur les bancs d'école
le massacre n'était pas mentionnée
la clôture elle n'a rien oublié de ce
qu'est la vue à l'âge de 7 ans des
images qui la hante depuis un massacre
qu'elle a récemment de nouveau vécu
devant les élus du congrès américain st
lô ses blagues au début du 20e siècle en
plein boom pétrolier greenwood un
quartier afro-américain de la ville
ségrégué de taussat prospérer tellement
qu'on le surnommait black wall street
hôtel théâtre commerce journaux cette
communauté n'avait rien à envier aux
autres
le 30 mai 1921 un jeune afro-américain
qui sera plus tard disculper fait
l'objet d'une plainte de la part d'une
jeune femme blanche
menacé d'être lynché un groupe d'hommes
noirs temps de le protéger
puis un coup de feu éclate s'ensuit la
destruction presque totale du quartier
de greenwood par une foule de résidents
blanc aidés par les autorités alors de
l'espace de vingt quatre heures
pas seulement les gens étaient vie de
l'homme de leur maison mais on a volé le
propriété ils ont mis aux incendies leur
maison des gens sont venus avec des
mitraillettes mitraille des gens dans la
rue il y avait des centaines de morts le
bilan du drame au moins 300 morts et
plus de 1200 édifice incendié parfois
même bombardé par des avions parmi les
commerces réduit en cendres le cabinet
d'avocats du grand père de john franklin
un historien qui se donne aujourd'hui
pour mission de raconter ce drame au
monde entier quand j'ai montré ses films
en suisse il ya quelques années les gens
parce que c'était l'europe après la
deuxième guerre mondiale je dis non je
regrette c'est des états unis en 1921 le
grand père de john franklin a été au
coeur des efforts pour aider les
survivants à reconstruire leurs maisons
si certains sont restés plusieurs
traumatisées ont quitté leur ancien
quartier
ce n'a jamais eu la même promesse ce n'a
jamais eu le même enthousiasme
cent ans plus tard des descendants de
cette communauté afro-américaine de tout
ça affirme n'avoir jamais atteint le
même niveau de prospérité que celui de
leurs ancêtres et la transmission de
richesse a été brisée assure ce
journaliste et activiste de taussat dont
les ancêtres ont perdu leur magasin de
couture en 1921 leur ancien quartier
greenwood et de nouveaux dynamique mais
l'embourgeoisement ne profite pas
nécessairement à la communauté
afro-américaine de taussat réclame donc
des dédommagements financiers que la
ville verserait aux survivants et
descendants des dix ans il mesure
proposée par une commission de l'état il
y a 20 ans qui ne s'est jamais
concrétisée selon lui l'absence de
réparation ni aux événements entourant
le centenaire ce vécu pour l'historien
john franklin
il faut avant tout profiter de ce moment
pour faire la lumière sur le drame
il souligne qu encore aujourd'hui
personne n'a été formellement accusé
d'avoir participé au massacre
ricco sella serait souhaitable
mais feu il faut deux côtés pour avoir
la réconciliation du côté des noirs nous
connaissons ses créations ceux qui ont
survécu mais l'autre côté restent
minimes
tout ça s'entend plus tard la page n'est
donc pas encore tourné le survivant
youthman alice a néanmoins un message à
partager nous ne sommes que seul pays un
appel à l'unité après une année qui a
rappelé qu aux etats unis les tensions
raciales sont loin d'être réglés
[Musique]